have to come up with a way a language
between you and your husband
that you can have some level of
vulnerability
and it's going to be something that you
have to practice whether that's a spiral
notebook that you'll share because you
can't say it out loud you're just gonna
just gonna write it down
whether that's a weekly meeting that you
have typed out that you hand him across
a table and he reads it
and it could be everything from
I wanted to hide when you came home hot
from work the other day
we've been having sex like this and I
don't like it anymore we haven't been
having sex and I miss you is it me do
you think I'm too ugly or am I too old
or whatever whatever thoughts are going
through you've got to figure out a way
that you can safely practice bringing
him into that conversation